okay next question David I've heard
politicians talk about postal banking
what is it and is it a good idea what
postal banking is the ability to do
banking services at the United States
Postal Service there is already some
pseudo banking services at the post
office like for example being able to
get money orders right people can go to
a bank and get a cashier's check or a
bank check some banks I guess have money
orders but the money order typically is
either from a for-profit company like a
Western Union or you go to your post
office and I think it's like a dollar
and you can get a money order and this
is a good way for people who have cash
but need to make a payment where cash is
not accepted to convert cash into
another form of payment so I think it's
a really great thing that the post
office offers money orders
people will say Oh money orders are
often used for for criminal activity
what isn't right so that's an argument
against Bitcoin that's an argument
sometimes against credit cards in the
pocket of skimming them cash is always
used for criminal activity okay postal
banking would be more which is that you
can even have an account like a checking
account that is administered through the
post office and depending on where you
live you might have very limited or no
banks in your neighborhood but because
there are ubiquitous post offices and
with the exception of like the very
rural areas where you might have to
drive really far to get to a bank or
post office there can be urban areas for
example that have very few banks but
they do have a post office so wouldn't
it be great if you could get more people
on the record within the banking world
by allowing postal banking and the bank
Lobby is hugely against this you've got
a huge Bank Lobby that is saying that
you've got to go and not you you have to
prevent them from doing this you did it
because there it's gonna take away from
the integrity of the bank services that
they can provide it's really just they
don't want to lose the money right
there's no good reason that banks have
put forward for not doing postal banking
other than what is the real reason which
is they're gonna lose money so I think
that this would be absolutely fantastic
I think it would be a very very
progressive thing to do but there are a
lot of factors that are pushing against
it and by the way supermarket banking as
well you could have supermarket banking
and I know that now there are more
more supermarkets that have banks inside
of them and that allows people when they
go and do their grocery shopping to be
able to get banking services as well you
can have actual supermarket banking as a
concept and it would serve as a sort of
check and balance on the really big
banks US Postal Service and supermarkets
could offer free checking accounts free
savings account that would prompt banks
to either match that or to have to give
better service because if it's the same
thing why would someone go to the bad
service at their big local bank rather
than the post office it would also I
think for rural communities be a really
really good thing and keeping money
quote under the mattress or in cash is
much more common in rural communities
and getting some of that money into the
banking system would would also be a
really good thing so I think that this
is a fantastic idea the reason we
haven't seen it is that there are a lot
of politicians who are in the pocket of
the banking industry as well as bank
lobbyists pushing really really hard
against it but I I challenge anyone in
the audience if you have a good reason
to oppose postal banking let me know I
can't think of one great bonus show
coming up today david pakman.com no i'm
sorry
join pakman.com that's the new URL for
becoming a member join pakman.com or
become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show that will get you
instant access to the bonus show